hello there citizens of the reject Nation
Greg here today I'm going to do a movie reaction
for the film inside out first things first
please go ahead leave a like doesn't take
too much effort on your end but it sure helps
us out a lot so thank you for doing that that's
very appreciated secondly yeah I'm a little
bit familiar with inside out I've heard thematically
what it deals with it's always sounded very
interesting to me and here's the truth I I
explained this in a trailer reaction not long
ago but I'll do a quick like 10 second recap
of it and I'm gonna watch what I'm gonna say
just because YouTube's hypersensitive here
I rented this probably in like 2015 and I
fell asleep about like 10 minutes in don't
remember those 10 minutes not because the
movie was boring but because I ate a special
dessert that uh 2015 Greg was taking quite
a bit of at the time and I knocked out really
fast so yeah never ended up watching the movie
and I had to return to film the next day I've
heard of this movie throughout the years I've
constantly nodded my head in conversation
with people like it's kind of look inside
out I'm like yeah yeah yeah and in my head
I'm like what I know of inside out but guys
I'm here to do it properly this time I'm ready
to focus and absorb this film also uh full
interaction watch along as we sync up with
your own copy of inside out I'm watching this
in Disney Plus available for super sexy Rejects
at our patreon page I want to say once again
thank you to all who have joined our patreon
thank you to all who support us there because
you guys have been astronomically beneficial
for us and at times just of massive savior
in our lives so thank you anywho let's finally
watch this
[Music] hmm
[Music]
and there she is so cute aren't you a little
bundle of joy
[Music] memories it was amazing just Riley
and me forever for 33 seconds [Music] I'm
sadness oh hello I I'm Joy can I just if you
could I just want to fix that thanks and that
was just the beginning oh there's so many
so many emotions okay looks like you got this
very good that's fear he's really good at
keeping Riley safe see easy huh oh we're good
we're good thank you thank you very much and
we're back
this is disgust she basically keeps Riley
from being poisoned physically and socially
that is not brightly colored or shaped like
a dinosaur it's broccoli Riley if you don't
eat your dinner you're not gonna get any dessert
wait did he just say we couldn't have dessert
that's anger
no dessert oh sure we'll eat our dinner right
after you eat fish tears are coming yep well
she
[Music] there's no place for her to go so
she's good we're good it's all great oh joy
can't exist without sadness to really understand
Joy but the really important ones are over
here I don't want to get too technical but
these are called core memories yes like when
she first scored a goal that was so amazing
damn I was psychologically deep is this gonna
get and each core memory Powers a different
aspect of Riley's personality like hockey
Island goofball island is my personal favorite
come back here you little monkey we love our
girl and she's got great friends and a great
house things couldn't be better after all
Riley's 11 now what could happen
dramatic memories we're getting close I can
feel it there it is here's our new house
oh it'll get better we're supposed to live
here I'm telling you it smells like something
died in here can you die from moving guys
you're overreacting nobody is done a dead
mouse oh no all through the drive Dad talked
about how cool our new room is let's go check
it out it's gonna be great yes yes yes yes
yes no no no no no no well guess what the
moving van won't be here until Thursday you're
kidding God
[Music] she's closing in Hey Oh no you're
not coming behind you watch out watch out
I wonder what the actual plot of the movie
is or is it just an exploration of Riley's
mind the investor is supposed to show up on
Thursday not today I gotta go it's okay we
get it see you sweetie dad just left us oh
he doesn't love us anymore that's sad
you know what I realized Riley hasn't had
much remember hey I saw a pizza place down
the street maybe we could try that pizza sounds
delicious yes Pizza is always a joyful emotion
what the heck is that we're disgusting broccoli
I like that time with the dinosaur that was
pretty funny [Music]
wait what what happened she did something
to the memory what did you do sadness thinking
of her dad making her sat
wait what what happened
oh no she's not finding the joy and the things
she once found joy in anymore she's growing
up why are you King really the opposite of
what we're going for here crying helps me
slow down and obsess over the weight of life's
problems you know crying can actually be very
emotionally beneficial for you long-term memory
data selection via Channel subgrouping see
fun already oh you lucky dog you're reading
these cool things I gotta go work life is
so unfair oh Joy just keeps pushing away the
sadness
a moving van
Tuesday can you believe it where's Dad on
the phone this new Venture is keep ing oh
no she's feeling neglected I guess all I really
want to say is thank you huh you know through
all this confusion well you've stayed our
happy girl your dad's under a lot of pressure
but if you and I can keep smiling it would
be a big help we can do that for him but would
that deny Riley her own emotions I have a
feeling this movie's gonna break me this is
surprisingly mature looks like we're going
into REM I've got dream Duty so I'll take
care of sending these great day today guys
I wish Joy would get to work on my dreams
oh this is it a new place
somebody order a broccoli Pizza ah gross I
not supposed to do this but
we are not going to end the day like this
no Joy here your Nevada is all wrong Joy
oh that's beautiful what are you doing in
there perfect this is the circle of sadness
your job is to make sure that all the sadness
stays inside of it oh no did you did building
a wall around the sadness
all the sadness stays in the circle
[Laughter] okay everybody we have a new student
in class today are you kidding me out of the
gate the anxiety my name is Riley Anderson
I'm from Minnesota and now I live here how
about Minnesota can you tell us something
about it Well you certainly get a lot more
snow than we do she's okay [Laughter] pretty
much everyone in my family skates it's kind
of a family tradition we go out on the lake
almost every weekend oh it's turning sad again
what
hagging stuff oh no Riley [Music] but everything's
different now since we moved oh Riley this
is so sad it's a core memory but it's blue
oh God no that's a core me
[Music] whoa what's happening
oh
thank you Riley I know it can be tough moving
to a new oh no she's shutting off her emotions
no personality islands and no you're headquarters
without you Riley can't be happy we gotta
get you back up there oh almost must hurt
Riley to feel right now
fascinating empathetic experience right here
I found a junior hockey league right here
in San Francisco here you you pretend to be
Joy want to be great to be back out on the
ice oh yeah that sounds fantastic yikes the
hone did you guys pick up on that what should
we do we're gonna find out what's happening
but we'll need support signal the husband
oh that's clever
that's really cool
oh she's looking at us uh what did she say
oh oh sorry sir no one was looking
signal him again
ah so Riley how was school time for this we
gave up that Brazilian helicopter pilot [Laughter]
school was great all right Riley is everything
okay tone Riley I do not like this new attitude
oh I'll show you attitude no no no no stay
happy oh no that's your problem just leave
me alone sir reporting high levels of sass
take it to Defcon 2. you heard that gentleman
Defcon 2. yay I don't know where this disrespectful
attitude came from you want a piece of this
pops come and get it yeah well look here it
comes prepare the foot ready to launch on
your command sir [Music]
that's it go to your room now uh put us down
the foot is down good job gentlemen that could
have been a disaster well that was a disaster
[Music]
Escape into those memories things got a little
out of hand downstairs you want to talk about
it come on where's my happy girl oh he's trying
to start up goofball this is so clever all
her dominating emotions are there this is
so fascinating I'm like so fascinated by this
[Music] oh goofball Island that means she
can lose friendship in hockey and honesty
and family you can fix this right Joy I uh
try oh we'll never make no no no no no no
no no don't obsess him
don't don't touch remember if you touch them
they stay sad oh sorry I I won't [Music] what
happened with the playoffs we won the first
game bushes we might actually go to the finals
this year oh and we've got this new girl on
the team she's so cool uh she did not speak
oh new girl Meg has a new friend already place
no need for Riley the newspaper is ready I
gotta go what I gotta go go go
[Music] Island no I love that one and now
it's gone goodbye friendship hello loneliness
Riley's imaginary friend and I'm Joy they
join well what the heck you doing out here
oh without you anyone ever be happy we can't
have that we got to get you back uh I'll tell
you what follow me oh thank you what a great
imaginary friend you are taking the train
[Music]
train oh good try this is abstract thought
what's wrong with that I'm not missing that
train Bing Bong knows what he's doing he's
part dolphin they're very smart well I guess
this can be dangerous yes I like how illustrative
like the animation is yet there's something
that's they keep it simple but not too bombastic
it's the right balance to strike for this
could have easily been just like Gonzo Madness
if they wanted it to be I'm gonna turn it
on for a minute and burn out the gunk
no they turned it on ah never seen this before
Oh God okay never mind I guess the thing I
was saying they might do what they're doing
abstracting there are four stages this is
the first non-objective fragmentation oh God
the train
oh no we're not figurative wait we're two-dimensional
fall on your face oh sadness you figured it
out [Music]
trophy Town medals ribbons everyone's a winner
all the dreams and there's always something
new like
who the heck is that imaginary boyfriend I
would die for Riley luck isn't gonna help
us now if she tries to use hockey Island it's
going down which is why I've recalled every
hockey memory I can think of one of these
has got to work in place of the Corn memory
she's about to play hurry
way to go fear
I'm rejecting it all
foreign
[Applause] box box
Riley can't be done with me no that's so sad
it's gone forever sadness don't make him feel
worse sorry it's all I had left of Riley he
can confide in sadness we were best friends
yeah it's sad
there's a comfort to be had in sadness when
you align yourself to just feel it this is
this is a touching movie oh nothing just the
best idea ever what all the good core memories
were made in Minnesota Air go we go back to
Minnesota oh no let's sleep on it because
hey I'm sure Jolly fun-filled times are just
around the corner
oh man she becomes super depressed
we're all on break yeah the train of thought
doesn't run while she's asleep it's really
not she wakes up sometimes when she has a
scary dream we could scare her scare her no
no she's been through enough already we're
gonna make her so happy she'll wake up with
exhilaration then that's never happened before
[Music]
I mean this is pretty scary this is not working
oh
you are ruining this dream you're scaring
her look it's working oh damn sadness you've
been pulling this off you might know Riley
better than Joy
I'm bingo what is this place the subconscious
subconscious yeah hey you oh you got us get
back in there no escapement
no escaping what is going [Music] handy wrap
it's a trail
thank you
very clowns huh
God it's so loud we still have to wake up
Riley but how [Music] scare her with jingles
follow us
this cannot be good for Riley's brain but
it is just her subconscious she's dreaming
[Music]
man sadness has been holding it down
[Music] so how are we gonna get to Minnesota
from here we're taking the bus Network there's
a bus leaving tomorrow no this is terrible
where would you stay Riley you're not thinking
this through
uh-huh
honesty Island
guys oh my God you gotta be kidding me
emotions at least for Salvage we have no core
memories you want Riley to be happy let's
get back to Minnesota and make more if we
hurry we can still stop her family Island
let's go oh you know what the sad part is
like Riley just needs a a moment to be vulnerable
you know just to take an opportunity to be
sad and express that have a great day sweetheart
see you after school monkey we love you [Music]
haha what a fascinating illustration of the
mind if you get in here
oh that is messed up oh what a bunch of [__]
Joy
[Music] this music's freaking effective damn
it's that phrase out here for years of like
if you keep Chan chanting into the garden
there's no ways there's no ways there's no
weeds the weeds will overtake the garden
[Music] it is very possible to block your
emotions by trying to like just do positive
affirmations and [__] but can't build
the house on the sand it'll sink eventually
remember oh she used to stick her tongue out
when she was coloring
interesting Joy's experiencing the sadness
[Music]
interesting She's Like Coming to Terms of
reality [Music] laughs
ah there is a joyful memory there
that's that's really well done
I came to help because of sadness we have
to get back up there Joy kid existed that
satisfaction
s
[Music]
don't give up persistence persistence come
on
[Music]
huh
we did it that was great that's what her imaginary
friend wouldn't do geez [Music]
I'll try Bing Bong like totally plays with
like whatever [__] childhood feelings
you have you know
sadness come on sadness where are you okay
if I were sadness where would I be oh everything
is awful and you have to drag me around why
touch all the [Music] oh no it's Mom again
what do we do [Laughter] it [Music] guys we
can't make Riley feel anything it's completely
shut off
[Music] wow [Music]
now [Music] wow
[Music]
that worked well what
would you do if you're so smart I tell you
but you're too dumb to understand oh my God
it's up to you me sadness Riley needs you
that's really sweet what a fascinating lesson
[Music] wait stop
how would you know how to get back
worried sick where have you been it's so late
okay that is fine [Music]
[Music]
foreign
and my hockey team I want to go home
please don't be mad oh
I miss Minnesota too I miss the woods and
we took hikes come here let's please don't
be bad
[Music] you did the sadness
it's beautiful man that's beautiful [Music]
everything's restored God this is not just
won't stop being washed the shirt
I'm not missing one go [__] ers
[Music]
she loves the face painting I told you it
was a great idea idea he's had in a while
he's a really good guy
just in case [Music] [Laughter] we've been
through a lot lately that's for sure but we
still love our girl she has great new friends
a great new house things couldn't be better
after all Riley's 12 now what could happen
[Laughter] that was wonderful that was absolutely
wonderful let's see what's in these credits
since the images are moving
[Applause] yay
what
a little very accurate [Laughter] yes very
true I love that let's talk about it ah yes
okay just gotta get a good stretch in here
yeah that was very moving that was very very
touching I love the hell out of it guys that
was an amazing film um it's one of those movies
where like the messages and themes are the
centerpiece of the film and they are like
just driving the entire narrative forward
you know and it's crazy to they can make something
that feels high stakes out of something that
is not it's like because we'll make something
feel high stakes in a film is why is is is
how how it could feel like life or death for
the main character pretty much like you know
the circumstances themselves are not like
that high stakes but when you go to the recesses
of the mining you see the emotional turmoil
and the challenges that Riley is going through
uh that that makes it feel like I stick so
it's pretty crazy how they they put this picture
together I just was watching it so fascinated
by by the whole construction because it has
a really like nicely woven message like with
with the most obvious one being that being
you know sadness is okay and that it's okay
to feel sad I just repeated it myself I just
repeated that but yeah being sad is okay and
that there's something meaningful to it and
and that the main thing that you have to learn
to to do in life is to be honest with yourself
and with your emotions that and that like
really emotions it's not really that emotions
are good or bad and I think you know and depending
on what part of the world you live in um but
at least in the the sections of the world
I live in within Western societal culture
it often can be the case of you know that
there's a much higher emphasis put on you
know obviously positive thinking is great
there's a lot of power and positive thinking
there's a lot of power in you know good thoughts
and stuff but that's like what I just said
right there was the thing that I ought to
not be saying is because we often have a habit
of labeling our emotions as good or bad when
emotions are just emotions and we ought to
be more accepting of just how we feel and
be okay with accepting how we feel because
that's how we move on that's how we move forward
you know uh that was one of my earliest lessons
I ever as someone who's been in therapy for
like a decade at this point one of the close
to a decade one of the earliest lessons I
ever got because you know I was someone who
who got very much into of personal development
like a little over a decade ago and who had
a very much like toxic depressive mindset
at least that's how I Associated and yeah
it was I was just a very manic person and
uh I was really really I felt like I was really
personally volatile and angry all the time
and uh just depressed like constantly for
most of my life and when I began to understand
where they might come from you know in between
that time of understanding what I would do
with like personal development I you know
you would hear so much about positive thinking
and you know I was I was around for the time
when something like the secret the law of
attraction was was brought into the Forefront
and especially being I know it exceeds far
past Los Angeles but being out in La that
was so such a dominant subject and and and
one thing that I think when you think about
like law of attraction or or the power of
like positive thinking like you attract what
you think about it's not it's not really like
every emotion first comes from thought sure
and I think the power of like attracting what
you think about it's really you attract what
you feel and a lot of the times you know it
we there's there's way I I damn one of those
people who believes in the gray side of it
all like yeah like there's there's power and
powers of thinking there's power and and reminding
yourself of what to really be grateful for
and a lot of the time though you know some
people and I was exceptionally guilty of this
like life was not changing for me because
I would just try to reject I would just reject
it would be so hard to face the things that
I felt personally traumatized by by just trying
to pile like I got this like [__] toxicity
and baggage and I was trying to pile positivity
on top of there but that doesn't make for
a good foundation and I feel like that's what
the message of this movie really is more about
more than just going it's okay to be sad which
is a great message uh to convey like it's
so it's okay to cry it's so it's okay to show
your emotions it's okay to show how you really
feel and a big part in you know moving past
something it is first accepting how you feel
like it's it's one thing to be with your emotions
of when you're sad it's another thing to you
know to get lost in it and to become and dwell
in it so much to the point where yeah you
are just in a a void that that's the heart
that's the part where you don't want to get
two down there two down that rabbit hole you
know like life is just a struggle for balance
all the time and that's just what I believe
is that you don't want to go too far down
that hole uh but at the same time there's
that that other side where it is okay to feel
how you feel and not reject it because that's
the only way you move on you know grief has
been such a prevalent Topic in my life and
what a lot of people often uh I think a hover
between is the first and fifth stage of what
at one time one of my I've had a couple of
therapists in my life and one my first therapist
what she pointed out to me was was that because
in grief there's like five stages there's
denial uh anger and blame depression a denial
anger blame um bargaining and depression and
then the last one being acceptance and it's
not like and what she pointed out to me was
that those first four stages are all kind
of intertwined those first four of they're
all sort of like its own form of shock and
denial like those emotions that are coming
through are all sort of its own form and then
I think this movie represents that really
well because you know as a as a child like
with this Riley character is dealing with
of feeling hurt and not having a decision
in the matter and feeling like she has to
put on a happy face you know because Dad's
going through a hard time this is tough for
them but yeah I gotta be all smiles that's
what they expect from me and I so as so anyway
like that's as she's dealing with like she's
grieving over a situation because that can
be a traumatizing experience for someone where
they are uprooting their whole Foundation
their whole base their whole life and having
to start a new one and they got to mourn the
the life they're leaving behind so so I think
that you know when you're thinking about that
in association with grief because that's what
she is doing is grieving she's experiencing
those emotions you know from from those stages
of grief and then the the part that you have
to get to is acceptance right is acceptance
doesn't mean I'm over it necessarily like
this acceptance just means I I yeah I can
deal with the reality of it now and I can
I can move forward
but the thing about getting to acceptance
is you have to first feel all your emotions
and be honest with yourself like whenever
I'm around anyone with loss I always say like
the most important thing you do right now
is be honest with yourself even if it's like
I don't want to feel right now or I I just
really can't deal with this be honest with
yourself when you can't do that so that's
what I loved about it was this in in a day
and age where it's like I don't feel like
we're there's so much emphasis like if you
go on social media about a one Niche area
of of positive thinking which is not a bad
thing all obviously it's positive a positive
thinking where this isn't more of an encouragement
to be honest with yourself and a lot of the
time when you do that that can naturally pave
the way for you to feel a more sincere genuine
way of feeling happiness that these emotions
can coexist that they don't have to necessarily
cancel out one one another and they can help
support each other and that's what makes us
human um there's a book I read it's actually
not a religious book despite what the title
might make you think I'm not like I'm certainly
not a religious person this book was called
conversations with God and one of the things
that book really uh emphasized on is life
is about experience and you can't really have
one emotion without the other like in order
to truly understand one emotion you have to
experience the other so that's why like early
on in the movie I was like Joy you can't exist
Joy cannot really exist without really understanding
what sadness is like because that's what really
helps us to understand Joy is when we completely
understand the opposite and it's like that
with a wide variety of emotions you know so
I think with what this movie did and talking
so much thematically and like the movies thematically
on display the whole time and that's why I
loved it because it was that that was The
Narrative of the of the film like when everything
is collapsing and then when she like shut
when Riley shuts herself off when it becomes
too too painful to deal with it she's just
left in the stages of fear and anger and and
like disgust just these three emotions and
this is all because like to deal with joy
like can't feel Joy and dealing with sadness
is too hard so they're just pushed down to
the recesses of her mind and this is all that
she has to work with on the Forefront if there
was something that felt very real and and
truthful in that depiction uh I thought it
was it was great because like the characters
the emotions are written so well like it I
felt like I kind of craved a little bit more
out of the disgust character I think that's
one Mindy calling was playing I kind of creeped
a little bit more out of her in terms of just
the writing because yeah she was like the
least standout of the personalities to me
what and I think there might that might have
something to do with the fact that you know
the other emotions are more easier to pinpoint
where disgust seems like there's a specific
like oh this is disgusting the other emotions
can present a little bit more of a range like
Fear Can represent you know I once heard that
every emotion comes down to love or fear and
if you take any emotion that kind of belonged
to one of those categories but if you're gonna
break it down within the rules of this movie
of the mind you know like fear was able to
show you the anxiety parts of it all and those
kind of emotions and uh anger would have some
of those bargaining stages you know the blame
stages that I thought were great and uh yeah
sadness and joy learning from one another
I guess those are like the two Primal emotions
for for depicting this and I think the the
voice acting work by Phyllis Smith from the
office amazing work it's brought such sweetness
to the role Joy Amy Poehler what I loved was
bringing the right ounce of what I thought
was great about her voice over work and obviously
this isn't the writing is that she it is kind
of that thing I was talking about where you
try to push down like negative thinking with
positive thoughts instead of just kind of
admitting to yourself like I'm I'm actually
dealing with something kind of hard right
now instead of just admitting that to yourself
like that would shine through in her performance
of using optimism to push it away that was
excellent stuff with the Bing Bong imaginary
friend you know like that was heartbreaking
to me of of like because the imaginary friend
scenario you know like to me I felt like growing
up my am I having an imagination was was such
a in that fantasy and escapism was such a
big part of my my survival is how I would
put it and it's stayed with me my entire life
and you know you always hear the cliches of
like when you grow up you kind of start rejecting
that side of yourself you stop being as playful
be an adult but I feel like we're all we're
all really just all of us adults are really
just we're still our kids our childhood selves
just in a bigger form you know as we reform
from that like they call it the core memories
here and it's funny to hear that because that's
the word I would use in my life is core memories
understanding core memories and core memories
so often help Define us and what we ultimately
develop into over time and I loved I I loved
the the uh the aspect of the imagination is
the thing that helped find the the creative
way like Joy had to get creative to to pierce
through the again and then get to sadness
and to get to the headquarters and it was
that imagination that helped save like because
really this is all Riley's mind and and the
imagination of that character is the one who
to help save the day is the imagination side
so I thought that was really connected with
that and it was sad to see like Bing Bong
go away because it was interesting with Bing
Bong because he's the kind of character where
he was amusing but I was like he might be
a little bit annoying but then he wasn't I
was worried he'd get on my nerves but he did
it and then I felt I was really affected by
that moment when when he ultimately did fade
away to help Joy get the chance to get to
Edwards to take care of Riley imagination
helps saving and and I think a lot of a lot
of ways it can it's not not like using fantasy
to become delusional towards your reality
but there's the other side of it again it's
it's a gray area and I think what this movie
does is really help teach and illustrate to
embrace the gray area the collectiveness the
community of your emotions versus just one
way or the other and I think that's a powerful
thing to to say to adults and to kids and
pretty much everyone of all ages that's usually
what makes the best Pixar movies right the
ones that are for all ages and uh yeah I thought
it was great like the way they dealt with
dreams and the reality Distortion of it and
like yeah that's that's what dreams feel like
reality distortion and you know I think dealing
with the the idea that you know uh to keep
up happy appearances and when you're not maybe
don't actually feel happy and to be okay with
letting you know you don't feel like you have
to let everyone know but you can let some
people and on the ones who are most important
to you the ones you value if you're most people
doesn't give a [__] what's on everyone
I'm sure go for it uh but I think that's another
great thing to and still you know I live out
in La too where it was all over the world
but I really feel like in LA yeah it's really
hard for like oh it has constant keeping up
of appearances out here can feel like a facade
after a while a charade so yeah and I'm going
off the Dome here as I always do but rather
than picking apart the plot points I feel
like what I'm talking about that is the plot
points and that's what I think makes for a
fascinating discussion about an animated movie
is these are the this is the plot of the movie
so and you're just watching it play out in
a in a way that's digestible for for families
for children in a way that can just they can
be cute and fun and a great Learning lesson
but I think it's also one of those movies
I can imagine watching this watching as a
little kid and then watching it like 10 years
later and learning more like if I saw us at
five then understanding it better at 15. and
then wow 25 I could understand it even way
better 35 the older you get the more you might
be able to actually understand this so as
much as I was like I feel bad like I don't
think me in 2015 would have even understood
this movie that well honestly uh I might have
been like yeah it's fine but or like yeah
I really appreciate but uh who I am at 2015
in 2015 was is not who I am today and anyway
like I really feel like I'm a very completely
different person from that so it's it's just
gnarly to see what they what they put together
here and I'm curious what they do with the
sequel because I feel like there are many
you'd have to probably expand the emotions
out expanding characters out but there is
a lot you can do with a sequel that I'd be
very much interested in seeing because you
can go pretty mature too if you really wanted
to I hope the inside out it's gone All PG-13
or R right here they wouldn't do that there's
a version where obviously you could do that
so I think that would be crazy and the movie
was funny it was also like a really funny
movie if it was it found a lot of a lot of
great moments of of poignant humor as well
and you know it is the kind of thing where
I feel like I just get more from on a re-watch
and and because it is a it's a construct of
the mind you know even dealing with like long-term
memories and then if you don't nourish those
memories it can often fade away I thought
it was I thought that was great I thought
it was a really great film with a with a really
powerful narrative uh as well so yeah yeah
I I loved it um I wasn't expecting to talk
about it like this but here we are because
that's what the movie is at least my take
but guys uh what do you think about it I thought
the voice acting was great I think the music
of Michael giaccino should have predicted
it was him amazing great Direction overall
and uh awesome voice over work it was deep
[__] and deep in a way they kept it light-hearted
for the for the most part you know like it
was really not a good tone really strong tone
might be one of my favorite Pixar movies
alrighty well I'm done for the day thank you
for being here subscribe click that Bell leave
a like check with me on patreon [Music]